تعطينا تمثيلاً قدم لنا
العرض التقديمي ، لا يمكنك إسكات
صوتي جسدي خياري ، لا يمكنك أن يكون لديك
ممر عنيف لأنني كنت هو خياري
عندما كان عمري 14 عامًا كنت ضحية للانتقام من
الإباحية واستمررت في التواجد معها  في الوقت
الذي ذهبت فيه كل يوم إلى مدرسة ثانوية صغيرة محافظة للغاية
وبدأت أدرك أنني كنت
واضحًا وفي عملية إخفاء تلك
الهوية انتهى بي الأمر بالتحدث إلى الأولاد
الذين لم يكن لديهم حقًا اهتماماتي الفضلى
في الاعتبار وفي  في الوقت الذي
اعتقدت فيه أنني يجب أن
أتابع ما طلبوه مني لأخذ
صورة لنفسي ، لذلك أرسلت
الصور التي نشرها عبر الإنترنت
ونشرها في جميع أنحاء مدرستنا الثانوية
عبر رسالة نصية اكتشف أن
صوري كانت على الإنترنت مدمرة
وركلت وعانيت في صمت بينما
استمرت الصور في الظهور على الإنترنت
لسنوات ، ثم أدركت أخيرًا أن
هذا كان يقتلني ولا أستطيع أن أعاني
بعد الآن من مطالبتي بصوت عالٍ
لذلك بدأت في إخباري  قصة أرى فقط
أي رؤية في الهند لأي انتقام
للضحايا الذين لسنا من المشاهير أو
الذين لم ينتحروا بعد
تجربتهم ، لذلك اعتقدت أنه من
الأهمية بمكان أن يكون هناك تمثيل في
وسائل الإعلام
للأشخاص الذين وقعوا ضحية
للانتقام الإباحي  لكننا ما زلنا
نعيش حياة سعيدة وصحية وناجحة ،
لذلك كنت أشاهد قناة CNN هذا
الصباح ، وأعتقد أن ما قالته ليا حقًا
أتى بي إلى هنا عندما قالت
إنها أسكتت فراغها لفترة طويلة ولكن
رفع صوتنا أمر مهم حقًا.
فتاة صغيرة كان الناس يبيعون
صوري عارية في جميع أنحاء المدرسة
، لقد كانت تجربة مخزية
حقًا وسعدت أيضًا أن أشعر
بالخجل حيال ذلك ، حيث تم أخذ هاتفي المحمول
مني وجهاز الكمبيوتر الخاص بي وأي شيء
به كاميرا سأشعر به
فتيات العلاج  كنت أعرف من كان يتحدث إلى
الرجال ولم أرغب في حماية
أنفسهم وسألتقط
صوري وأرسلها ،
لذا فهذه قصة
شخصية لرحلتي الشخصية  ProjectSyndicate ar إن كلمة إباحي
مرتبطة بالضحية ،
من المرجح أن يلوم الناس الضحية على الأرجح ،
وأخبرني باستمرار أنه إذا لم
أرسل الصور لتبدأ ، فلن يحدث شيء من هذا
، وقد يكون هذا صحيحًا بالتأكيد.
المسؤولية تجاه حقيقة أنني
صببت البنزين في المواقف ولكني
لم تعجبني المباراة ، فأنا في الأساس أقوم
بتفكيكها إلى الأبد في
شاشة توقف ثانية لأكثر من 60 يومًا ويليامز
الذي باع جسدي مثل جزء التدريب ،
يمكنك اللعب بمباراة لك  لا يمكن أن
تكون هناك دائمًا ارتفاعات منخفضة جدًا ، ولا
أعرف عدد الأشخاص الذين سيظهرون حتى شهر
مارس ، لكنني لا أعتقد أن
عدد الأمور التي ينشرها موقع الكلية
على الإنترنت ستكون
بنفس أهمية وجود أشخاص بالفعل
على الأرض ، هذه ليست
قضية جيل الألفية ، إنها قضية عابرة
للأجيال ، كل جنس ، كل
عرق ، كل اتجاه جنسي
وليس شيئًا يخجل الناس بسبب
الانتقام ، إن الإباحية هي تكتيك لإظهار الكراهية
ضد الناس  le لا سيما الأشخاص
الضعفاء الصغار والموجودين في الخزانة لا
يستخدمون أصواتهم للتحدث
[موسيقى]